this has been one crazy
week in america so we're gonna do our
best to talk about it tonight and
to process it and then we're gonna push
it aside
and try to have some fun okay does that
sound good to you terry sounds great to
me
okay so now like most americans i was
glued to the news this week watching
that insane series of events unfold
a mob of trump supporting terrorists
stormed
the u.s capitol on wednesday in an
effort to overturn a fair and legal
election
and subvert democracy it has honestly
been
a lot to take in and my personal
feelings have ranged
from rage to devastation to
embarrassment but the largest takeaway
for
me feels too important to put into words
so i wanted to put it in a song
at least it wasn't
that's right black people got to sit
this one out and just watch it from the
sidelines and frankly
i love that for us so if black people
didn't create this mess who did
well there seemed to be some confusion
in the media about that this week
the press was calling the folks who
stormed the capitol building
protesters and trump supporters and in
one case
west virginia state delegate that's an
actual west virginia state delegate who
filmed himself storming the capitol
building
i'm not making that up but in actuality
the people who gathered in washington on
wednesday
are nazis traitors and fascists
that's what they are i don't know why it
is so hard for reporters to call them
that
it's easy look i'll show you in a game
called nazis
traders or fascists
this police officer opened a gate to let
an angry mob
into a government building now which one
is he a nazi
a traitor or a fascist that's right
he's a traitor and how about the guy in
the camp auschwitz shirt
that's right he's a nazi now this guy
with the confederate flag
that's right he's a traitor that flag
literally
means traitor there was a whole war
because of it
senators josh hawley and ted cruz they
tried to stop the electoral account and
overturn
our democracy making them that's right
fascists and traitors and of course
this [ __ ] is all three this has been
nazis traitors or fascists
see that was easy i can do it and
i didn't even go to a journalism school
i'm just a lady with a math and some
words now
as anyone with eyes can see wednesday's
terrorist attack was committed by for
the most part
a big old bunch of white people look at
that
that riot was whiter than a piece of
chalk clapping on the ones and threes at
a little big town concert
it was so white the queen of england was
there
well i assume that was the queen of
england because if it wasn't
why would police be helping her down the
stairs
now i get why white men are mad
they've had control over this country
for 200 years and now they feel like it
might be slipping away
they've been cheating the system and
they know the jig is up but
why were white women there to feel
superior white supremacists need someone
to treat like crap
and when there are no black people
around who do you think is the most
expandable
that's right white women and on
wednesday the capitol police showed
these white women just how expendable
they are
they were beaten up and maced and even
killed
but despite that white women continue to
align themselves with white supremacy
55 of them voted for trump this year why
women
why are you signing up for this [ __ ]
those white men hate minorities and
you're a minority
you think you're a member of the cool
club but that's not true because
one this club is not cool
and two they hate you you can't be the
oppressor
and a minority you need to pick a lane
and the lane you're choosing
sucks this one is way more fun
it's the only lane with good food now
we've talked a lot so far about what
this white mob did at the capitol
building this week but
what we have not talked about are the
consequences they faced
because there weren't nearly enough
police did not intimidate them with riot
gear they did not fill the
capital with tear gas or use rubber
bullets in fact
in one instance a police officer was
caught on film
taking selfies with the rioters
hey cap hey calf hey calf
hey cap what is happening why are they
taking a selfie
cops treat innocent black people like
criminals and criminal white people like
fans at a bts concert
and two days after these events unfolded
the vast majority of people involved in
this event
still have not been arrested they have
not been reprimanded by the police in
any way
which brings us to a segment called one
time
[Music]
this man is stealing a podium from the
u.s capitol
one time i was stopped by the police for
skipping down the street
they stopped me and frisked me for
skipping
and that is not a bit this man
broke into nancy pelosi's office and put
his feet up on her desk
then he stole a piece of her mail and
posed
for pictures with it one time the police
followed me to my house for being
outside of my house
they made me go inside of my house get
my id and prove i lived in my house
because i had been outside
of my house this man dressed up like a
viking and stormed into the senate
chamber
one time when i was wearing 100 totally
normal clothes
and riding with my friend in a normal
car i got reprimanded by a cop for being
a prostitute
this man climbed onto the deus in the
united states senate threw his fist in
the air and shouted
trump won that election one time
a police pulled a gun on me for no
reason just kidding
that wasn't one time it has happened to
me multiple times
i've been harassed by the police one
million times for nothing but
these people put on their maga hats and
guns and broke the law
and punched and pepper sprayed and
fought cops and most of them went home
and faced
no consequences a bunch of them went to
this fancy hotel
and hung out in the lobby like nothing
happened
just straight lounging you know what i
thought when i saw that clip
i wish i could walk around with the
freedom these people enjoy
just one time
now the news was a crazy mess this week
but there was
one common theme in the chaos
politicians and reporters couldn't stop
talking about how shocked they were
but i wasn't shocked i knew shenanigans
would be afoot the second i heard that
patriots were gathering at the capitol
to save america
look i would never racially profile
anyone but there's only one thing whiter
than a grown man and a manga hat waving
a confederate
flag a patriot ask any black person what
they think when they hear the word
patriot
and they'll tell you that a patriot is a
racist with a flag pin
now if i was walking down the street and
someone said here comes a patriot i will
run
and when patriots get together nothing
good happens
i bet they laughed their asses off at
the first patriots meeting in 1776
when 41 slave owners signed the
declaration of independence
all men are created equal good one
tommy j do me a favor peek outside and
see if my negro is still tied up next to
my horse
a patriot is defined as someone who
loves their country but
these people actually hate america you
know who loves america
the people who fight voter suppression
the people who fight
for the rights of the less fortunate the
people who risk their lives to try to
make america keep its promise to
everyone
not just to some people a common refrain
i keep hearing this week was
this is not who we are but unfortunately
that is not true this is who we are
america
is not better than this we have seen it
over and over again the last four years
and we've seen it throughout
american history america is built on a
foundation of oppression and prejudice
and
unfair distribution of power the
founding fathers set it up that way and
we've been living with the consequences
ever since
so if you've been saying that this week
stop stop saying this is not who we are
and start asking what can i do to change
it
because in the meantime every white
person and your grandma is trying to
bring down the government
no i mean your grandma was there come
get her
wait wait don't go anywhere i have big
news i have my own youtube channel now
yay be sure to subscribe for a lot of
show clips and a lot of digital
exclusives
and a lot of this see you there